all right well anyway here are some
BuzzFeed lists post crazy I think I
could have done that for 40 minutes
they were just perfectly happy with gogo
and I felt like a parent whose child was
being applauded for bad behavior yeah
yeah yeah which is yeah I'm sure you'll
be gone tomorrow but I have to live with
this with this month yeah yeah
anyway premises BuzzFeed's running out
of lists here's some BuzzFeed lists I
saw recently check this one out 47
people who are peeing in the hot tub
right now oh yeah oh man look at him go
so jr. loves it check this one out 11
douchey jazz musicians playing a vape
pen like it's a flute this 144 dogs
fantasizing about their previous owner
while humping their current owners leg
[Applause]
[Music]
though this one 13 star wars-themed
divorces
if you're a fan you got to do it you got
to do it if you got married Star Wars
you got to get the Borah stores hey look
at this one
21 photos of nude celebs that no other
website would buy one guy was like oh
you'll take it and like it nine states
where it's legal to punch a guy riding a
unicycle yeah look at this one 11
captures that were distressingly
personal check this one out seven times
a bridezilla actually destroyed Tokyo
well that's 12 guys with obscene
sideburns now that's not right
good work with the Clippers oh yeah I
don't blame him I blame the barber yeah
yeah for this one 17 extremely rare
photographs of deep-sea creatures
wearing their retainers and finally 10
sins God will forgive but won't forget
[Applause]
[Music]
you